hey grammarians hey paige hi david today
we're going to talk about dashes which
is a piece of punctuation looks kind of
like this
um it's just kind of a straight line
later we're going to talk about hyphens
which looks like this
and there is a difference between the
two of them it's kind of confusing but
first we're just going to talk about
dashes what they are and what they do
okay sounds good to me so dashes have
approximately four uses
use number one is that they can mark
interruptions in the structure of a
sentence as in
i ran to the bus stop but the bus had
already driven away
so we're using this dash to interrupt
the structure of this sentence
okay but
couldn't you just put a comma there you
know you you totally could you
absolutely could use a comma instead of
a dash but the dash has this feeling and
i'm gonna make up a word here it feels
more interrupty
okay
right so a comma sort of helps the
sentence keep flowing and the dash kind
of stops it for a second and even though
grammatically those two sentences are
identical right i ran to the bus stop
comma
but the bus had already driven away even
though that's
technically that means the exact same
thing as i ran to the bus stop
dash but the bus had already driven away
this is kind of like an abrupt cut off
so like the comma right the the dash is
uniting these two independent clauses i
ran to the bus stop the bus had already
driven away right so like you know comma
but would connect those two independent
clauses the same way that dash but is
connecting those two clauses
but it has a slightly different
connotation it's just more abrupt in the
way that it connects these these two
things together okay also
it looks like you don't have a space
before after your dash is right is that
right so originally when i drawn it it
did look a lot closer but yes in
according to the chicago manual of style
that khan academy uses um it would just
go
word
dash word then a space but when you're
using dashes generally
you don't put you don't put spaces in
between them
in between in between words right
so that's use number one it can
interrupt the structure of a sentence
use number two for the dash is that they
can act like parentheses
in
pairs so the dash is
in the same place as it as another type
of punctuation could be again correct
okay the dash i guess is kind of like
so let's look at another example
sentence and i'll switch colors the bug
which landed on my nose had to be the
size of a softball
enormous bug but paige as you rightly
pointed out you know it's this is the
same as having it in parentheses you
wouldn't have both of these together
like that but they do the same thing but
they yeah they have the exact same
function in this case in this case so
when you have them in pairs like so it's
the bug which landed on my nose had to
be the size of a softball so it's kind
of this aside
if we really wanted to we could take it
right out of the sentence kind of like
in a positive write with commas
so we could say the bug had to be the
size of a softball sentence still makes
sense right
use number three a dash can be used
where you would otherwise use a colon
so
in this case it's going to be sort of
introducing something right
so the colon has this linking power
right it can introduce ideas it can
start a list you can do the same thing
with a dash
so for example if we wanted to introduce
an idea we could say
i have only ever wanted
one thing
snacks me too paige so many snacks me
too
uh so right so we're using this to
introduce this idea the same way that we
would
had it been
a colon okay so the dash is like a
little actor yeah
yeah the dash is like an actor that can
just like
do the jobs of all these other these
other punctuation marks so it can be
parentheses it can be a colon
it can be like a comma sometimes
wow that is a that is a talented little
guy seriously i'm very impressed and the
fourth use of the dash is again to
indicate interruptions but specifically
to indicate interruptions in speech
this is like its own little special
thing yeah it's not acting like anything
else nope
just
indicating interruption as it does
watch out for that wham
so so we're using this dash to say
that
this sentence was interrupted by
something and then you know we deploy
the sound effect um but it could be
anything really so if you're if you're
trying to
write down dialogue that is being cut
off by something by another person
interrupting by
avalanche of
ice cream i don't know you know whatever
it is um then you would use a dash at
the end of the sentence so no space so
it would go that dash
quotation marks
and you wouldn't have to do any kind of
terminal punctuation no need for a
period or a question mark or an
exclamation point
the um
the dash kind of serves that role
of course
because it's a very fancy actor so i
wouldn't say i wouldn't say that the
dash as an actor can perform the same
roles as terminal punctuation as periods
or question marks or exclamation points
but rather i would say that it's cutting
off the sentence before we can even get
to where those would live okay yeah it's
saying
there would have been more words in this
sentence and then terminal punctuation
but
so that's what dashers can do
they are used to mark interruptions in
the structure of a sentence
like i ran to the bus stop but the bus
had already driven away
they can act like parentheses when
they're used in pairs so like the bug
which landed on my nose had to be the
size of a softball
you can use them like a colon to lead
into
lists or to link an idea
so i have only ever wanted one thing
snacks
and they can indicate interruptions in
speech like watch out for that wham
jasket thanks
uh and those are the functions of the
dash
you got it you can learn anything david
out page out